the biskits jr. was named because its
earlier design the biscuit was used to
shoot horse racing scenes in the film
Seabiscuit it solves those problems by
creating a low profile engine that sits
right underneath the actual picture car
the innovation is the remote systems
drive pod and this allows the actors to
be in the hero car with the actual
driver out of sight of the cameras
multiple camera angles capture realistic
looking driving while the actors can
focus on their job safely and without
distractions the biskits jr. has been
used in high-profile films including
Drive which involves some extremely
tricky stunt driving and most recently
in the Academy award-nominated
Nightcrawler for this innovation the
Academy presents a technical achievement
award to Robert Nagle and Allen paddle
foot gentlemen unbuckle your seat belts
and come on up today
hi I am Alan Fidel furred and this is
Robert Nagel and I'd like to take thank
the Academy for bestowing this most
prestigious award to Robert and I I
would also like to thank some of the
great people who took the time to sing
the accolades of our work that brought
the attention to the Academy and that's
our Roger Deakins and Robert else whit
Elia Popov Matt Sweeney Darrin Prescott
and in addition many thanks to Gary Ross
and les Tomita for having faith in our
idea for the original movie that we used
it for which was Seabiscuit and last but
most certainly most importantly thanks
to our wives Robyn and Shannon for their
support in this crazy business crazy
crazy business my sons Kyle and Riley
who are headed for the same business our
dedicated crew a talented Elford camera
cars who build the vehicles and maintain
them and of course all the hard-working
men and women of our extended film
industry who've been a fan and supported
us for all these years
thank you very much thank you